we would just buy cool-looking domains so that we could have like a hundred character long vhost
so that it says like i.am.in.your.computer.today. And just these we would have like a whole message
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
i'm not sure you all know this but two of the most respected hackers in the ctbb
community bus factor and xss doctor are now running monthly hack alongs on the ctbb discord okay
you've got to check this out ctbb.show/discord we find bugs almost every time we hack it's crazy
and and oftentimes it's not even the people running the hack alongs it's the the community members that
are hacking along with us it you definitely increase your chance of finding a bug by being on
these hack along so check them out ctbb.show/discord join bus xss doctor and yours truly and let's pop
some bugs all right let's go back to the show sup guys got the this week in bug bounty segment for
you uh yes we hacked dropped another great blog alex brumans i tell you man what a researcher
um this article that he released that i want to cover real quick called python pitfalls has some
crazy crazy stuff in it that i've definitely missed in prior assessments so check this out
the first one is in python's os.path.join which i've seen many times
so in the example here he says os.path.join passes in slash user slash uploads and then the payload received
from the user right well if you give it just an absolute path it just ignores the the prefix right
so if you give it as arguments i'm trying to put this in audio for you guys os.path.join slash user slash
uploads is the first uh argument and the second is slash etsy password that will resolve to slash etsy
password it'll just ignore the prefix uh which is super crazy to me so uh yeah don't even worry about
path traversals you can just put in the absolute path uh very odd um and then there's also this one
down here it's the same sort of situation uh which is apparently urllib.parse.urljoin does the exact same
thing but for domains so consider this you have uh urllib.parse.urljoin the first parameter is http
colon slash example.com and then the second parameter is http colon slash evil.com so you're
you know providing an absolute url the output of that is evil.com it just removes the whole example.com
piece which is nuts to me um so python's got some crazy weird quirks apparently you should just be
yeeting absolute uh file paths and absolute uh uris everywhere into python and it just will just accept
it um so check out this uh article we'll link it in the description there's lots of other good stuff in
here like pickle deserialization and stuff like that okay so that's that um next is actually a quick
announcement that i wanted to remind you guys we talked about it on the google cloud episode but
um google cloud vrp is offering a bonus to all critical thinking podcast listeners if you mention
the podcast in any rewarded report between now and the end of april you will get uh an extra reward either
cash or swag um so definitely want to do that so drop some love for us in those cloud reports you guys
are putting in and get yourself uh some swag all right that's it let's go let's jump to the main show
dude tommy man i've been looking forward to this episode for a long time because and this is a special
episode for me as you guys know because tommy is a part of my hacker origin story uh especially in the
bug bounty world so dude i owe you a debt forever for introducing me to bug bounty that day and the
reason that happened was yeah true but the reason that happened was you just showed up at my vcu
college cyber security club and we're just talking about bug bounty randomly how do you remember how
that happened whoever the president was i don't remember his name yeah parker yeah yeah so he had
emailed me or reached out to me on twitter i don't remember which one it was and he had asked me um if
i would come and talk to you guys about it and i was like yeah i guess i had absolutely no idea what
to expect i wasn't expecting uh like 10 nothing against all but kids yeah standing in a what was it
it was like a computer lab yeah it was a computer lab we we like grabbed a corner and stuck like a
server rack in there yeah and yeah i wasn't expecting what it ended up being but it ended up working
out i had let um both uh hacker one bug crowd or i guess all three hacker one bug crowd and senate
i had to let all three of them know that i was going to go be uh going to be doing it nice and asked each
one of them to send me some uh stickers and swag and stuff to get out i think hacker one was the only
ones that actually did yeah you sent us gave us some good stuff bug crowd and uh cynic didn't or they
couldn't end time something i don't remember but um yeah he emailed me or dm'd me on twitter that's so
funny man do it and since y'all were local i was like yeah anytime because it's like 10 minutes from
my house sure i'll pop in there yeah whenever well it's funny because i was running you know he's my
co-president and i was running the the labs at that time you know and then you just showed up
you know and i was like he didn't even tell you about you didn't even tell me yeah oh man he didn't
even come yeah no he didn't even shout out to parker man i don't know if you're listening but uh that
was the most poorly organized thing that had the greatest impact um so yeah definitely grateful for
that well um you know how we do it here on the pod i guess we didn't even really talk about this
beforehand but typically on on the podcast what we do is have guests bring a vulnerability that they
want to talk about you know and and give us a little uh summary just to you know prove some expertise
obviously tommy devos guys we don't have much to prove here uh legends but if you have anything you
want to a bug you want to run by us or you can talk about your more recent fuzzing stuff or um well the
fuzzing i can't talk about the bones yet it hasn't been long enough to where i'm allowed to disclose
them right and i don't really want to make google mad yeah i like them being nice um i guess my favorite
bug is still from yahoo in 2018 that bought me my gtr um i was in las vegas in october 2018 i had
like moved out there halfway for most of 2018 and um i was waiting for my friend steve we were gonna
go do something at night i don't remember what it was but uh he was taking a shower and he was like a
i don't want this come across the wrong way but he took forever to get ready like a girl like it took
him almost two hours to take a shower do his hair and everything and it's like dude no but i was bored
and i went and took out my computer and i was sitting on his um kitchen table and i didn't want to start
hacking on anything new because it's like i only had a little bit of time i don't want to could have had
15 minutes could have had two hours yeah exactly and i don't want to get into something and then have to
stop it like this morning having to walk away from the computer was driving me nuts i'm so sorry dude
like literally he popped an rc on one of his bugs as he was walking out the door yeah like i literally
did it and then i had to walk out the door but i was worried about doing that back when i was at his
house so i went and opened up my hacker one reports and just picked a random ssr from yahoo and decided to
start playing with it and i had had all kinds of success in coding the ip addresses in different ways
to bypass because they used a blacklist they didn't use an allow list they used the blacklist
and blacklists are very very very bad well i don't even know why it worked but i was super stoned so i
decided that i was going to take the aws metadata ip and instead of encoding the entire thing i took just
the first 169 and octal encoded that left the rest of the ip the same and it worked for some reason
i have absolutely no idea why you why logically it shouldn't have worked and i was just trying things
because i was trying to pass time well it worked and i got the aws um credentials again oh my gosh then
i went back into my reports and i pulled every single ssrf that i had against yahoo from the last three
years and it worked on every single one of them so i went and filed 18 new reports each for each one of
them was a unique location and everything but they needed to go and update their deny list again and
they paid me 10 grand for each one so i got the 180 grand and then that's nuts four days later i flew
back here to richmond and sat outside of the dealership that had my gtr until they were open at
10 30 in the morning and told them that it was mine now wow dude that's crazy so so you had um you went
back to all of your previous reports so that's one i think that's a great takeaway for the listeners as
well it's like if you do have a short amount of time perhaps to hack go back and look at a report
that you think you may be able to bypass or something like that because then you don't have to find spend
time finding something interesting yeah exactly it's a it's a great way and i mean things change so even
if it's not bypassing the old vulnerability they might have added new functionality to the exact same
little area that you can quickly play with and you already know at least enough about it to find some
vulnerability so anything that's different there it's it's less of a learning curve to
to translate from not doing anything to instantly be no excuse me to get in there and hack right right
make sure you don't bump your mic when you're when you're doing that um yeah dude totally i think that
um i think that that technique is really interesting too because obviously so just to speak it out you
know plain and clear you had an ssrf you were going to hit 169.254.169.254 which the aws metadata
endpoint which was going to drop back the access credentials yeah because i had already done it in the past so i
already knew the exact path and the key name and all of that stuff so i was just trying to find a new way
to represent the ip address that they hadn't accounted for nice and and the way you did that
was taking that first 169 just the first one because if you did any of the other ones it wouldn't work
or if you did the entire ip it wouldn't work it had to be the first 169 for some reason i'll have to
look that up i'm not sure but i imagine what happened there is that when you had that first octet
encoded with four characters rather than three right yeah because it's like it's like oh two it was
like oh five two six or something something crazy like that like it doesn't even when you're looking
at it it doesn't even look like it's a valid ip address wow but that's it was according to yahoo it
was at least and i actually just saw recently um within the last two weeks i saw some other kid
on twitter post that he did the exact same thing not to yahoo it was for somewhere else but he did
the exact same thing like just a couple weeks ago and it's still working so it's still something that
is valid today it's still one of the things that i try anytime i find something that i'm going to test
for ssrf wow nice man good good bug i think that uh you were the first person and i don't know if you
were the first person to discover it at all but you were definitely the first person i heard talk
about the aws metadata url as well and also this octal encoding so uh for a lot of the bug bounty
community i think that was uh you know you were the introduction into that for the octal maybe like
i remember the first time i hit the aws server was actually on yahoo as well i was sitting in aws reinvent
up in dc yeah that's right yeah i had gone up there because me and a friend of mine here locally
josh we had started a company here in richmond for security and um we wanted to go up there as part
of the company it was right before or right when i was leaving my previous job and getting ready to do
bug bounties full-time and that's where they taught me about the metadata server i had no clue what it was
and i'm sitting in a in a talk there with my laptop next to josh and then they told us about the ip
and that it could be used to get the uh the access access credits and everything and i was like hold up
so then i actually sent sam zlz a message because we had been hacking on yahoo and there was this place
in their small business you used to be able to go and buy hosting and domains and stuff from yahoo
small business and there was a place on one of their main front pages where you could give it a url
and it would go take a picture of it for you and we used that to take a picture of the aws access
credentials course and that was the first time i'd ever gotten it to work it's so funny you talk
talking about this because i i don't remember very much from that era at all of like what was going
on in life and stuff like that i remember everything that you just said like it was yesterday man like
the yahoo that's all i remember as well aws stuff i was like wow this is the most interesting thing i've
ever heard and my brain just like clamped on it like you know um so very good times back in the day
watching you and sam oh it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun and they had stupid like we weren't even
finding anything crazy it was just stupid simple excesses and stuff like that because it it's
exceptionally hard especially when you've got a website builder as part of your product it's
exceptionally hard to do that in a safe way and yeah it took yahoo a while before they were able to do it
but it wasn't that was good scope it was good scope man yeah i was sad when they took it out yeah i was
real sad so so you know pulling on that thread a little bit like you i've already talked about how
you're you know a part of my origin story as a hacker but also you were a strong influence on
sam sam curry and corbin leo uh and some of the other earlier on hackers um that kind of popped up in
the scene and started you know going to live hacking events and stuff like that um so i mean
was that something that you were always trying to you know do intentionally or was that just a part
of you being early on in the bug bounty scene you think um a little bit of both uh
i'm older than most of y'all by quite a bit and um it's been really important to me to try and get
younger hackers including all the way down to kids like in middle school involved in it um i got curious when i was in
like late elementary early middle school so i know about when kids start getting uh
interested so that's why i like going and speaking at middle schools i haven't spoken at in an elementary
school i don't think that would be appropriate because i'm not sure that the kids in elementary
school are quite uh knowledgeable enough about computers as a whole like they know how to open up
robux or minecraft that's about it but once they're in middle school they're actually
have the ability to take classes programming classes typing classes and that kind of thing and
they're actually using computers more and i don't want them to make the same mistakes i did it's uh
i have been having this conversation a lot the last couple of weeks but when i started we didn't have
virtual machines we didn't have a lab that you could go like try hack and try to hack and all of that kind
of stuff we didn't have any of that our practice was the real world we had to go and hack real systems
and if you wanted a challenge you had to go and make really stupid mistakes and hack government military
systems yeah yeah okay so let's let's go down that path a little bit here so that was a part of your
origin right you were a black cat earlier on and um you know got got caught and kind of reformed there
do you want to give us like the the you know five minute version of that story so that we can
have that context yeah um irc was a fun place in the 90s we like to take channels from each other
so we built very very large botnets um to ddos people and yeah you're i don't even know if you're
old enough to remember there was this kid in canada named mafia boy uh back in 99 2000 he's credited with
the first large scale ddos attack when he ddos like uh ebay and like i don't remember all the sites
but it was any of the big sites that were on the internet back in like 2000 and he was actually the
kid we were fighting on fnet for our channels he was a member of tnt and i was with tdk those damned kids
and we were constantly fighting over the channels with him so that botnet that he used against
like all the fortune 500 companies all the time he hit us with it a lot and it would take us offline
a lot but i spent a long time doing that i changed in about 2000 thought it'd be fun to deface websites
so i started doing that when you were doing the botnetting how are you getting these compromising
these machines was just rats are you like no no no there was no concept of that no like the only
right there was at the time was uh like sub seven and then cdc uh the cult of the dead cow put out uh
back orifice but and there's they were only windows based yeah when i was a hacker we had a rule in our
groups you weren't allowed to hack windows it was too easy it was too easy dead ass don't need to cuss
but you weren't allowed to have windows at all we felt that hacking windows was too easy um but every
system back then could be hacked literally there was no such thing as a secure system right because these
things were designed without thinking that somebody might want to break into it over the internet the
internet was still barely knew it was 10 years ish old maybe a little bit less so it was it was a
completely different world there was no such thing as a web vulnerability i don't even think we had
databases like for you to store it didn't have databases no it wasn't a concept it was stored on disk
like if you were to go to a website and purchase something they would actually save your name address
credit card number and all of that into a text file on the web server like on the web server all you had
to do was break into the web server and go find like cc.txt and you had a list of everybody's legitimate
info that's crazy dude what a what a time this was before we had those little three-digit codes on the
back like i remember being a kid and we had credit card generators where you could literally open up this
tool click a button and it would give you a credit card number and an expiration date it didn't need the
three-digit code because that didn't exist yet they created it because of this fraud time period i
bought probably a hundred thousand domains no domains for like a dollar a piece just by clicking this
little button and say hey generate me a credit card and it it would just generate one you didn't need any
name or anything like that it was all you needed was the 16 digits and a four digit um what a what a time
man yeah because they didn't they weren't connected like they are now to uh i don't even know the paper
process companies anymore but they weren't connected to them in real time to be able to actually validate
them and everything like that so i think most of the companies would just kind of like
if it was the proper format and looked real yeah then they would accept it and then they would find
out a couple of days later that oh it wasn't valid or something like that so but it was with four
domains back then to go on irc we always wanted a bnc and it was just a a vhost it allowed us to hide our
isp and ip address behind it and you used to have to pay companies each month for them to create you a vhost
because then they would create you the vhost and if you paid them the five dollars a month or whatever
they would make that vhost reverse dns to a certain ip address so that way you could go on irc with it
and everything and it all looked right and we would just buy cool looking domains so that we could have
like 100 character long vhost so that it says like i.am.in.your.computer.com and just these we would
have like a whole message that's our host name wow dude what what a time so after the irc era you
kind of moved into website defacement right yeah i imagine that was your your intro into like web
vulnerabilities and stuff like that no no there were still no web vulnerabilities okay there's no such thing
okay so like there wasn't like websites back then were written in either html static files or yeah it
was yeah it was like i don't even i don't remember if we even use javascript yeah like um i'm trying to
remember so would you just like use some network level exploit to get access yeah yeah it was always it was
always we would root them through telnet ssh ftv root them through telnet yeah telnet every telnet uh
solaris which is sun os yes whatever you want to call it um all versions of bsd freebsd netbsd bsdi open
bsd uh i think there was one more too i think there was like five of them would they just leave telnet
open like or would you have to use the telnet exploit or what you would use the telnet exploit but you got
to remember something everything had telnet back then we ssh was new ssh was new in the
mid mid 90s i want to say mid to late 90s was when it was starting to be adopted and it was significantly more
common for them not to have ssh than it was for them to have ssh so everything was telling it so the the
whole process was use a telnet exploit or whatever the exploit you wanted to use whether it was telling
it we um rpcs rpcs on unix boxes listened on port 111 i think it is every single rpc that listened on that
port had a remote root exploit every single one printers names are bind what underpins our name
circle that had tons of vulnerabilities back in the day and that was a huge target for us we always
wanted to compromise name servers um but we would compromise them and because everybody was using
telnet we would install packet sniffers key loggers on it so that we could get the telnet credentials
of anybody that connected to that machine and used it to connect to others so we would target university computers a lot
taiwan korea
and hong kong those three countries were they were always farther behind like most the rest of the
world like we're running linux 5.2 they're still running like 4.1 for example so they were always
running super old operating systems that always had vulnerabilities anytime you needed shells because
our rule was you don't hack from your own system right you never hack from your own system so you would
get either take the risk that first time and hack something overseas and get the access to that box
or you would get somebody to give you access to a box overseas and anytime we needed shells we would scan
the entire class a of 200 dot and 210 dot because there you were guaranteed to get a few hundred root shells
well over scanning those we we would write auto routers that would yeah i was going to say how are you
routing traffic through these things that are you just like hopping on by a telnet and then running the
exploits from there or okay that's all we would do is uh now starting in the late 90s and early 2000s
we weren't using tone it anymore we were using back to word versions of ssh so that way it was encrypted and
we would have our rootkits installed so they couldn't see anything that we were doing and have our hidden
directories and everything and we would just use those essentially as a jump box we would use those to
do the hacking and do the connecting because back then we figured that it would just be a lot harder
for them to a the websites that we hacked would trace it back to that korean or the hong kong or the
taiwanese server and then we were banking on the fact that they weren't technologically advanced
enough to be able to trace it from there back to us so so i mean that sounds like good play man how did
you how did you guys get caught oh people tell yeah people talk yeah that's the that's what it always
just about came down to um cowhead got arrested because of defcon in oh one at the alexis park
um you know they have the little um scavenger hunt well the scavenger hunt that year took you to
a uh pay phone that was 24 karat plated gold on the wall he ripped it off the wall and took it to him
instead of taking them to it because you got to remember something you didn't really have camera
phones back then so you couldn't just take a picture with your phone right show them you found
it so instead of taking them to it he ripped it off the wall he got arrested at defcon we all went home
a week later he puts on our website he makes rafa makes a graphic for him and then he puts it on
cowhead put it on our website and it was bragging about him getting arrested at defcon for ripping
the payphone off the fbi monitored our website duh so they saw his post they went to las vegas said hey
tell me who you arrested during this week for doing this oh no they gave him his information in tennessee
so they went to tennessee and he was 15 years old i had broken into the um wait cowhead was 15
years old at this time yeah what how did he get did he live in las vegas how did he get to defcon
that's what i'm getting ready to uh explain my god this is crazy um i'd broken into the utah dmb
computer systems so i could actually create fake ids but mine if you got pulled over by a cop and
handed them your id you were okay because i would actually put you into their system and yeah all of
us had an id that said we were 22. i wasn't but 17 almost 18. oh my gosh and your parents were just
like oh they didn't care they didn't you were just gone yeah like hey mom go to a conference bye no i
didn't even it wasn't even that it was just i left you just like from the time i was like man 13
from about 13 on i could pretty much do whatever i want like i got expelled from school in 2000
and my punishment was i went on vacation for a month in new mexico with other hackers
oh my gosh so well that is uh that is one way of doing it i guess so okay so he gets he gets caught
they monitor the fbi site or the fbi monitors that site they track him down and then he was only 15.
yeah he had pictures on his computer of him and his girlfriend who was also 15. so yeah people don't
understand right that that still counts as child pornography right so they threatened him to charge
him with possession of child pornography even though it was him and his girlfriend consensual and all of
that they threatened to charge him unless he told on us so he's hold on everybody he didn't know enough
about me to know where i lived or anything but he knew enough about one of our other members noid
and uh noid actually lived over in charlottesville oh really yeah me and noid went to king's dominion
and stuff a few times together and they caught noid when he was boarding an airplane to go he was brazilian
and he was boarding a plane to go back to brazil because we had found out cali had gotten busted
and they caught him when he was getting ready like literally getting ready to board the plane wow
he knew enough about me right so out of the 13 members of the group there was only one that didn't
tell me wow it was raffle wow dude that is uh that is a crazy time just trying to like put all
that together in my head it's like you guys were so young yeah that's nuts and boarding planes
like crafting these fake ids and like that's nuts man yeah it was it was a fun time i got a lot of fun
back then and i wouldn't change any of it so so you got caught you went away for a little while how long
were you in prison and and the first time two and a half years and then i came home and when i got
expelled from school they banned me from touching a computer because one of my charges during the
expulsion was for computer hacking as well so they banned me from computers and then when i got released
in 06. i'm not a fan of people telling me i can't do something right so i didn't listen i stayed off
a computer for like a month by february i was back on the computer and it's got to be tortured man like
yeah especially being like i'm adhd the only thing that can keep my interest is computers yeah hacking
and security so it was like i was working bullshit jobs as construction i was a chef for a little while
and it was just boring i hated it and i started getting back on the computer again i started
i joined another group called core project under a different name that time uh and defaced a few
websites again one of them was yahoo they got real mad at me it was biz.yahoo.com and um uh for that one
i wasn't allowed on computers my probation officer would show up at my house randomly like at least once
a month he had come over like a week before so i was like he's not gonna he had never come again for at least
three or four weeks in between visits so i figured that was good i was sitting on my computer one day
and i had my computer set up in my room so that i there was the walls were like this my computers were
right here and i was sitting right here facing this way but literally right beside me i had two giant
windows like double the size of this window right here yeah so that i could look straight out into my
driveway and my driveway was pretty long he had to come into the driveway and then turn and come down
a little bit turn again and then come back so you'd have some time so i had some time i see him pull in
like starting to pull into the driveway and i panic yeah i jump up out of the chair start taking
laptops weren't as prevalent back then so it was always desktops so i start ripping everything apart
i take the keyboard and the mouse throw it onto my bed as i'm taking the tower out i don't remember
where i hit the tower but i hit the tower somewhere in the house came back got the monitor hit that
somewhere else these things are heavy as shit at that time too yeah they were yeah i forgot to grab
the keyboard freaking keyboard man off the foot of my bed uh probation officer comes into the house
and one of their things that they do is a inspection so they walk through every single room of the house
and look through every they aren't allowed to actually search search but they can come in and
anything that is within their view they're allowed to use against you so damn it dude he had me walking
him through the whole house and opening the closet so he could peep his head in and everything and we
got up to my room and the keyboard was sitting on my on my bed and he used that as saying there was
enough uh probable cause to say that search or something no to consider me in violation of probation
because there was no reason to have a keyboard if i didn't have a computer so he violated me on my
probation and the funny thing is he gave me my little violation hearing for like the next week i went to
it i had been doing a lot of drugs but i was using these drinks and pills that are supposed to clean
your system and i was having to take a drug test three times a week and i was taking these and
god i can't they never said nothing your body man they never said nothing to me right when i went to
court for my violation they called me out i had failed 17 tests in a row for cocaine yeah you're
passed them all for weed and i took every test high so the drinks and pills i was using it was these um
these like cleaning things that you take it you drink 32 ounces of water and you're clean for six hours
yeah i was taking those they're just like little detox things and they worked for a weed they didn't work
for coke and i had no idea until i show up and the judge is like yeah well you've got 17 violations
for a failed drug test for cocaine and then for and they never told you once they didn't tell no not
until i was there dude so then they gave me another year so i went back to prison for a year or a little
under a year and then i got out again in
in late 2008 i think it was so then that time i was i was good when i came home that time i didn't go
back to hacking i got an xbox and started playing call of duty which i wasn't allowed to do i wasn't
allowed to have a game system i was gonna say like dude that's computer violation um i started playing a
browser based game my sister had come up from florida to visit with her fiance at the time and um he was
playing this game called evany oh yeah dude yeah so he showed it to me and was telling me about how
people were finding exploits and stuff like that in it they were making money selling resources so i was
like i'll give it a try i wrote the first part you said you were good dude hold up you said you were
being good i was just playing games i wasn't hacking oh sure i was just playing games but i wrote the first
block for evany and then um there was a business two doors down from me at this time and they got broken
into and the only thing that was stolen was computers ah the cops in hanover they know my history yeah i've
been running in with them for a very long time at that point and um they swore up and down it was me
rafa was also doing black hat hacking again from venezuela and he had somebody in america working with
them they swore that was me so they watched me the fbi watched me for six months and could not get any
evidence against me so then they used the burglary at the business two doors down as an excuse to raid
me and look for those computers and then find anything else they could lock me up with so i was up playing
evany until 5 30 in the morning on no october 8 of 09. i went to bed and laid down between 5 30 and 6 and
the next thing i know it's 6 15 and i hear something banging on the tour so i went downstairs and i peeped
around the corner because we had those glass things beside the door so you can see outside yeah and i could
see people standing out there but they're beating on the door saying police get out the house i live
like at the time i lived like two miles from a jail yeah and people escape from it every once in a while
and when they do they search our areas and i thought somebody done escaped from the jail and they were like
in my backyard oh my god so i go and open the door and they bust through that door they bust through the
door with their m16s they handcuffed me and this is in october it was cold as hell i'm in just sweatpants
because i was in bed they've got me handcuffed for over an hour laying off face down on the floor
in my living room while they secure the house and then they found a few computers and xboxes and stuff
like that so they sent me back for a year and a half that time but it was the reason they sent me
back for a year and a half was because they were trying to build a case against me for doing stuff
with rafa again and i kept trying to tell them every time y'all ever come and arrested me for something
once y'all get to the point where you show up at my house it's too late to deny it they know it was you
if they ended up at your house you know if you're actually the one that did it so i've always been
honest like you come and kick my door in and say hey were you hacking this i mean you just kicked in
my door i'm gonna admit it because i'm gonna try and not get in as much trouble right you have at least
enough that led you here i kept trying to tell them that it wasn't me and they didn't want to believe me
so they gave me was it 16 months 15 16 months that time to build the case and then four months into my
sentence they came and visited me and apologized they found the person that had broken into
the business two doors down yeah and they had found the person that was working with rafa that was
working with rafa so i asked them hey does that mean y'all are gonna get me out of here let me out of
here and they were like well you were still in violation of your probation for having the game
system cell phone and the computers but they killed my probation okay so and they removed the limitation
that i i was banned forever from a computer and they removed that from me kind of as like their apology
that's presented me back so that's a great a great uh yeah it ended up working out because
otherwise i wouldn't have been able to do bug bounties or anything right otherwise i still probably
would have done it but i would have just gotten in trouble and then you would have this uh year year
in prison every couple of years it's life it's life if i get in trouble again for computer crimes it's
life that's why i that's why you're really really that's why i yell at people all the time about scope
they don't understand the only reason bug bounties are illegal is because the company says yes you can
do this if you follow these rules if you follow if you deviate from those rules what in any way shape
or form there is absolutely nothing you can do to prevent a cfa violation all it takes is one pissed
off chief legal officer one day or one company to be having a bad time and then you go out of scope and
them just say all right you know what screw it and they go after you and it's like just because it
hasn't happened yet doesn't mean that it can't and i'm not willing to take the risk okay let me ask
you your take on this then because you've you've hacked with sam a good bit sam does a bunch of
like just i'm gonna hack this company and do a write-up about it under the name of security research
and he you know i've talked to him about it at length and he's like i'm i'm pretty sure it's under this
like fair usage policy of these websites you know for security research purposes and i say dude i
wouldn't do that only if if they explicitly have a vdp or bug bounty program yeah you're legal if they
don't and you do not have written permission it can't even just be them you know a friend that works
there and he said yes you can no you have to have written it's no different than a pen test if you're
going to go pen test the company you wouldn't pen test them without having scoping documents over what
you're allowed to hack what are your limits and everything it's no different so there's a lot of
people that will pick a random website and my big problem is when these now i'm not saying sam would
do this because i'm absolutely certain sam is smart enough to know that if he finds a vulnerability
doing this the first thing he does is email security at company.com not privacy at company or legal or
or support trying to scare people that's a good uh it's a noise the hell out of me and the my biggest pet
peeve is when people claim to be experienced security researchers and their first email for something
like that goes to privacy or legal or randomized email addresses it's like no you're you're not an
experienced researcher or anything because any any researcher knows logically the first thing you do
if you find a vulnerability check if they have a program on a platform if they don't you email security
yeah why am i going to email their legal team to tell them that their spf record is messed up yeah exactly
yeah no no it's bad man okay so so i guess that's a good transition though into bug bounty when did you
first hear about bug bounty and um yeah well 2014 is when i first heard about it that's when i created my
accounts on hacker one and bug crowd but i didn't do it so at that time do you remember how you heard about
it like um i want to say it was twitter twitter because i was extremely active as an anon but not in
like i didn't do online ops like i i wasn't ddossing websites i sure i i still consider myself an anon
but i disagree with the route most of them went yeah i don't think breaking into if your target is pfizer for
example i don't think you hurt pfizer by breaking in and stealing their customer data and releasing that
right because you hurt the end user exactly and anonymous that's my biggest complaint about anons is
that they they're accepted lateral damage is a lot different than what i would do yeah um but
so you heard about the bounty via twitter by twitter you made your accounts i made my accounts but it
wasn't worth it because it had only been at that point a couple of years since you told me it was life
in prison if i get caught hacking again never heard a bug crowd never heard of hacker one and it seemed too
good to be true and then late 2015 i started seeing a post on twitter that were bug bounty write-ups like
such and such getting paid x amount of money for a vulnerability they found and everything and then
finally early 2016 in late january february i was like all right you know what i'm bored as hell at work
let's give it a shot i opened up hacker one tried to register and it said that an account already exists
with my email i didn't even remember signing up for the account so i recovered the email or recovered
the account logged into it and went to the little directory of the programs and i saw yahoo so i was
like he said hmm it's gonna be that yeah i knew a little bit about yahoo um and yeah just started
gave it a shot yahoo gave me my first bounty in march 2016 300 and then my next bounties after that
were for uh hacked the pentagon wow dude and i'm pretty sure i finished first and hacked the pentagon
and so hacked the pentagon they advertised it a bit gave us 30 days from all of may of 2016
to hack on the fuse host and stuff like that it was supposed to be like uh a limited event of all kinds
they would invite us to it we assumed that if you got an invite to the program that they had already
done whatever they needed to to clear you found out after it ran and after they owed me like 30 grand
for vulnerabilities that you had to pass a background check in order to actually collect
the bounties i got pissed yeah i went to twitter and vented my frustration oh no about finding that out
no it ended up working out um one of the people that was running the program she saw my post and hit me
up in a dm she was like i 100 understand your frustration give me 24 hours and 24 hours later she hit me up and said
you now pass background checks and you are going to get paid so now if you do a background check on me i
pass it ah wow that's kind of crazy yeah wow well i'm i'm glad you got that redemption opportunity there
yeah i was i was super mad because i spent the whole month because i had just gotten into it totally
i'd just gotten into it and they weren't letting us hack the u.s military from my experience in the 90s
and early 2000s the u.s government military were some of the easiest to hack into so i was really
looking forward to doing that for bug bounties it's also one of the reasons i stayed on cynic for as long
as i did because i only i only did government military targets on them i left them when their new
legal team decided to ban me from legal uh from government military targets oh man you keep getting
it man that's yeah that's crazy um wow all right man well how has the bug bounty industry changed since
that time like i imagine back then it was very fresh i mean do you think things are more difficult now
obviously there's more mass adoption but um
i don't know that it's more difficult it's definitely different because there's so many more companies
that are doing it um there's a lot more competition but i'll be honest 99 of the competition is not
actually competition for anybody that has any kind of skill right however the vast majority and i don't
mean any disrespect to the people but the vast majority of people that i see on infosec twitter and
x whatever you want to call it they're never going to succeed because
they i don't think they have the right type of thinking like anybody can run an exploit but yeah i feel
like you've got to have a certain logical way of thinking to figure out how to break because computers
do everything logical they do exactly what they're told based on certain conditions and part of being
a hacker is figuring out how to break that logic of what they're expected to do and just most people
aren't they just can't do it yeah i think there's something special about it i've been trying to like
figure out exactly how to call it but the only thing i've landed on is like reasonable attack vector
ideation you know like being able to look at a system look at the security boundaries look at the
implementation and just have enough understanding about computers in general and about the logic of
that app to come up with a reasonably feasible attack vector yeah but the problem is the problem is
a lot of times our successful attacks there's no reasonable reason they should have succeeded like
there is absolutely no reason this should have worked but it does but that's just one of those things that
even when we know something's not going to work we still do it anyway because we have to see it at
least for me personally i have to see it for myself and i it doesn't make sense why a lot of it works but i
i think there's more competition there are tons of really great hackers out there but the only thing is
like there's like there's so many programs out there that you can realistically find a couple of programs
that you want to focus on yourself and make decent money if you really wanted to but i i will probably
get to that so yeah well i wanted to swing back around to ssrf and and what attracted you to ssrf as a
vulnerability originally because i think at the time ssrf was not as popular of a vulnerability early early
on in the in the bug bounty arena in the in the you know offensive security world and and then you know
you kind of went down this path and really raked yahoo over the coals with the hat yeah it was the main
reason was because i have a lot of fun beating deny list blacklist whatever you want to call it um ssrf
is one of those vulnerability classes that historically the main way they try to fix it is to blacklist
whatever it is that yeah exactly and there's just so many different ways that you can bypass it
that it's it's just fun and it's a challenge it was back then it's not so much anymore because at this
point i've got a couple of dozen different ways that i encode ip addresses and it's if i find something
i'll script something to run through and test every one of my variations and things like that and if it
doesn't work then i'll move on well depending on the target if it's a target that's a big enough
target and everything then i might pass it off to ai at that point and say hey i've tried all of this
see if you can come up with absolutely anything that should not work that ends up working yeah but
i my main reason for ssrf was because i like beating the blacklist it's just it's fun dude it feels
freaking good man it feels good to get around the list like that yeah it's like it there's no other way
to describe it then it's similar to a high because you get that dopamine rush and it's just like yeah
you know other people looked at that exact same endpoint too and when you're like none of them were
able to figure this out and you were it's just one of those things it's just like that much better and
that the programmer sat there and said oh this i'll get them right i'll get them with this
regex you know and then they don't escape a dot or something yeah or they forget the little question
mark at the end and things yeah it's crazy man it's crazy it's a lot of fun um sweet dude so you
mentioned ai how are you using ai nowadays in your in your workflow i know you're just well adding a
little context you're just coming back from a little bit of a bug bounty hiatus and i know you're focusing
more on fuzzing now yeah how do you see ai in your workflow um i'm using it a lot for the exploit
development aspect of it yeah um i imagine that's really helpful it is extremely helpful um
i am having it do most of the exploit development but i've got some restrictions on my ai they're never
allowed to delete files every couple of minutes they have to do a brain dump into a file so that way i
can read through it because i don't want them doing things 100 for me i want to learn how to do it
so i've got them doing little brain dumps explaining why they did something what they've tried that's
failed like i don't want just the information almost succeeded i need to know what you tried that failed
as well so that i can learn for the next time that i'm doing this and everything um i've started to use
it a little bit when it comes to writing um my harnesses for the fuzzing um trying to i've been
targeting chrome it's no secret that i've been targeting chrome i've uh before i would go in and
find the functions that i wanted to fuzz and i would just write a very very basic fuzzer that would just
call the api for that function and fuzz that but now i i ran into several instances where i found a
vulnerability but it wasn't reachable in chrome so i've got ai now where it builds my harness to
essentially mimic the exact same flow it would go in go through if i were to load it via a webpage okay
so you just gave me a bunch of information that we're not going to air but um so i guess the tldr of
the situation is you are focusing on a sub technology within chrome and right now yes because i'm
trying to learn it i've never done browser hacking before right so i'm i'm trying to learn it like i
haven't even started to learn about the ipc how they're passing things from one sandbox to the next
one and all of that kind of stuff and i haven't done i've done almost everything that i've done so
far has been within the renderer itself i do have a separate vulnerability that i actually need your help
with because i need you run windows i think i do i'm running windows there so i need you to uh
to test a vulnerability for example i'm like 99 sure that i've got to use after free in chrome but it's
only uh reachable on windows i tried installing a windows vm and no yeah we didn't i i couldn't figure
out where the start menu was okay so so you're you're using ai right now to build these harnesses that
trigger certain code paths within the code within the chrome code base yeah that follows the same
path because when it comes to chrome it's like they've got all of these kind of protections and
validation so that as soon as you open up your website as soon as it starts to load and everything
before the first bit of its loading they're running all kinds of checks like if there's script tags
making sure that the the javascript is legitimate if there's image tags making sure there's valid video
i mean images in there video tags valid video and that kind of thing all through all of that and figuring
out that just because there's a vulnerability behind all of that the vast majority of them are blocked by
the validation that uh chrome does before it ever can reach the uh vulnerable chrome uh code path so i've
got mine set up so that it actually sends my what do you call corpus yeah yeah my my current test file it
sends it through the harness and the harness is designed to first go through chrome's validation
and then through the next step and then the validation of whatever's in the actual area because
if it's going to fail those i can't actually exploit do you have that isolated or are you hooking into
chrome and like loading up html files or whatever it depends and then it depends in some instances it's
isolated some instances i'm just running like a pure c or c plus plus program that calls the exact same
methods that chrome does in the same order i see and then i'm sure most people have seen by now the css
zero day that came out like last week that was uh exploited in the wild i'm fuzzing for similar
things to that right now where i'm actually doing it within browser as well one of my amd machines i've got
32 um chrome instances that are running and then within them i wrote some uh little custom javascript
things that run in the the web page on each each side that's doing all kinds of testing it it hasn't
found anything yet i'm not even certain that it's going to work but but we give it a shot yeah i mean
you don't know if it's going to work until you try it so i i've got to try it nice man yeah that that
definitely sounds like ai is helpful for all that because it requires a lot of isolation of code within
the chrome code base it requires and it's a huge code base it's a huge code base and that's something
that uh is helpful is making sure you understand
the ais we have access to are good at different things yeah so
like for example if i want to look at the entire chrome code base i'm only going to use gemini
yeah gemini with your paid subscriptions and the paid max or whatever it is that i've got you get
like up to 2 million tokens of context yeah you need that context to be able to not forget when you're
trying to have it traced through hundreds of files did you clone down the code base are you having it like
navigate okay yes i've got got it all down i've got probably six different or like six unique checkouts
of chrome i've got an asan chrome m sand chrome a ub sand chrome a normal vanilla chrome a debug chrome
and exploit dev chrome um all like i it's heavy man that's a lot of code it's heavy and it's hard as
hell to actually build chrome from source oh my gosh there's so many problems and dependencies so
i try and keep absolutely everything in its own folder so that way because i mean if you're
when you're fuzzing if you find a crash and you might need um asan address sanitizer in order to find it
well if your libraries and stuff weren't most recently compiled with asan you might have compiled
them with msan memory sanitizer instead you have to go through the entire process of rebuilding it again
so i've got a different it takes time it takes hours yeah depending on your system so i've got a different
folder for each different version of it and then i've got i it when i go through the process initially on a new
target i go through everything that it takes to build it for every version that i need and then i build shell
scripts that will essentially be able to because when you're fuzzing you've got to you change things a
lot like every time i find a vulnerability i patch it locally i i don't want to sit there and spend the
next two days discovering the exact same vulnerability over and over so i patch it locally and continue fuzzing and
then because it lets me get farther into the code base yeah because everybody else that's fuzzing it
if you're not patching it you're going to keep getting stuck at that exact same spot you're going
to have no way to know if there's more vulnerabilities with the patch reward program you you submit that
patch you get an additional you know bonus you know that that code is getting implemented but not even just
that because that's great google actually has it so that even if i find a vulnerability for example in a
third-party library that chrome uses but it's not reachable in chrome i can still go to the upstream
maintainer yeah report the vulnerability put a patch in for it after 30 days if they accept
my patch and merge my patch in after it's been merged in for 30 days with no like problems or anything like
that you can go file it to google because they've got the concept of open source uh yeah forgot what
it's called but you can the open source vrp thing yeah anything that you can like you fix that is a
material enhancement to the overall security of anything that google uses then you can get i think it's up to
like 15 grand you can get depending on what the bones are and stuff so yeah i haven't i haven't looked
thoroughly at this vrp very much but yeah there's a ton of open source projects that they yeah look at
this one of them uh supply chain compromises can get up to 31k yeah dang yeah and they like google's got
running i'm looking at you man lupin go go do this run depi on this um yeah dude they've uh they've got a
lot of stuff trying to care for the ecosystem i think you know um and then microsoft is now trying
to do the same oh really microsoft just made their announcement a couple weeks ago i guess been a
month or so ago now maybe a little bit more where they're gonna start actually paying for third-party
vulnerabilities and stuff that they hadn't previously because they want to also try and help uh
increase the security i've heard i've heard microsoft's upping their game i'm i'm excited to see more from
them i'm gonna end up right now i've been doing google my goal is to try and be top three or five for
chrome vrp through through this year and once i find a couple more bones to at least see myself up there
it's crazy though man because some of these guys just drop like you know fully fully built out you
know straight rce and just one you know but like and then it gets like 250k or whatever it's like yeah
so the max that mine the one that i've been working on can get is like 55 because it's within
the renderer but the one that i'm gonna have you help verify whether it's actually reachable or not
yeah that one could be more because it's in a what do they call it uh high privileged sandbox process
there we go so that one can get a little bit more up to like 85 how are you how are you
determining what seg section what sandbox all this is in are they oh it's in the code you just know um
like uh like uh there's the gpu sandbox there's the renderer sandbox and then there's the actual chrome
process itself and i've most of my vulnerabilities so far have been in the renderer process i've got
one in the gpu process um i actually found it because i was trying to figure out if there was a way to
escape the sandbox with the vulnerability that i've been working on there's not i need a completely
separate vulnerability for it but i did find what i'm 99 sure is another vulnerability it can't be used
for this kind of chain but it could be a completely different unique reportable one so
you've got ai helping you parse the code base build out these harnesses build out these shell scripts
sort of helping you get into browser-based hacking um do you i mean do you find yourself doing a lot of
the hacking via these ai agents nowadays for this stuff or are you doing stuff you're doing manually
versus having the ai agents go do it so i'm not gonna lie i spend a lot of time having ai agents go do
stuff nowadays well they're doing a lot like say i get a new crash um they'll be doing a lot of the
rca for me like helping me trace through the exact flow of whatever it was they got there because
they're so much faster like i can do it dude but they can do it in two minutes where it would take me
an hour or two so i naturally will have them do a lot of that um i haven't gotten back into web hacking
much yet i'm trying to i'm just struggling to get motivated and find a program that i want to actually
google's fun man google is fun to hack on it especially for web it is like it's challenging
you know oh yeah it's very hard because they're not using a lot of just straight json you're dealing
with a lot of proto json you're dealing with a lot of like you know just arrays that don't have any
keys you know like you know thought about looking at amazon like i mean amazon google gcp and stuff
i've toyed around with going back to amazon and doing someone amazon had a ton of success hacking with um
uh sean and um jonathan jonathan yeah for a couple of those aws events we were doing made a decent
amount of money so i've thought about going back to that it's just hard to get motivated to want to
do that and i'm having a lot more fun doing the fuzzing right now yeah man if you're having fun with
it you know that's that's the main game for us at this point i think right yeah because it's like i
i don't want to say web stuff is too easy but it's not as much of a challenge
so my goal i like i want to attend home to home one time dude i want to compete i really want to do that
that's why i am main the main reason that i'm looking at fuzzing and binary exploitation and stuff
is because i i want to do it just one time just to prove to myself that i can do it yeah so dude we
should uh we should we should do it man i've talked about it on the pod a couple times and i've had a
couple guys from ponte on on but um you know obviously the binary exploitation piece which is a
lot of ponte on is not a forte for me but i have done a little iot stuff and there is a good amount
of oh yeah yeah and uh and web stuff is actually really applicable to these systems some of the iot
systems it is for sure because that a lot of times is going to be your front door yeah yeah yeah so
some of the guys i was talking to were saying like yeah definitely like you need to have a good
skill set in reverse engineering and binary exploitation but also like if you have a really
good web guy you know then that would be helpful for a ponte on team because uh because definitely
there are those exploits out there the thing is it's just got to be unauthenticated rce which is like
you know a tall order um yeah yeah yeah now my big problem with it is that it's generally got to be
unauthenticated unauthenticated rce but also unsandboxed and everything like that like if you
want to go and pop chrome for it you don't get many points if it's rce and the renderer you need that
actual sandbox escape yeah full system compromise and stuff it's tricky man yeah my my my goal is to
compete and compete in uh ponda own at least once yeah and i want to get the max bounty
one time for google i want the 250 for a uh full sandbox escaped rce and chrome that would be sick
dude that would be super sick well maybe we'll do maybe we'll do a richmond ponte own team man me you
turbo you know uh that would be that'd be a fun one all right dude well that was uh that was quite
a run i have to say those stories are are very unique and uh thank you for the part you played in
the in the bug bounty ecosystem man and and and for me personally like really i i know i keep saying it
over and over again but when i think back to that day in that stupid little lab in vcu like crazy to
think that that was such a juncture point in my life yeah and it's it's like we didn't do nothing but
sit there for what about an hour yeah just talking looking at bounty reports yeah talking about the
different types of bounties and bugs and companies and stuff like that it's crazy how everything kind of
evolved from that it's uh yeah it's nice it's fun yeah dude thanks so much man no problem thank you
and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there